Je suis Roumain.
Enfin, je suis né en France, mais ma mère m'a dit un milliard de fois:
Tu sais Cyprien, ton père et moi nous sommes Roumains, donc tu as du sang 100% roumain.
Oui, mais pourquoi tu me dis ça quand je prends une douche, exactement.
Hein ? Ah, pardon.
Il m'a fallu du temps pour l'avouer. C'est pas l'origine méga stylée à la base.
C'est cool quand tu dis :
Je suis Américain.
Je suis Italien.
Mais euh, je suis Roumain
Et ça s'est particulièrement vérifié quand j'étais à l'école.
C'est marrant ton nom de famille, t'es de quelle origine?
Je suis Roumain.
Mon nom de famille c'est Iov, I.O.V, trois lettres, ce ne sont pas des initiales.
Et c'est dingue parce qu'il n'y a que trois lettres,
et pourtant depuis que je suis né, je suis tombé que sur des gens, qui n'arrivent pas à l'écrire.
Votre nom s'il vous plaît -  IOV, i o v.
Non, i o v.
Non y a pas de E.
Voilà, voilà, voilà, c'est ça!
Et en plus de mon nom chelou,
mes parents ont eu la très bonne idée de me donner un prénom presque inconnu. Alors là, euh...
Cyprien Iov.
Tu te fous de ma gueule, c'est une blague c'est ça?
Tu vas t'appeler Nicolas Pichard comme tout le monde.
Cyprien Iov (gné gné) c'est nul en plus à entendre, c'est nul.
Je vais t'appeler gné gné gné et bah voilà.
Mais la faute que les gens font le plus,
c'est quand ils voient mon nom de famille avec un I majuscule, ils lisent :
Lov, c'est américain?
Non, c'est roumain.
Malheureusement je ne parle pas roumain,
parce que mes parents parlaient essentiellement français chez moi...
sauf pour dire des insultes.
Du coup je ne sais dire que des insultes.
*parle en roumain*
Je suis déjà allé plusieurs fois en Roumanie avec mes parents, la dernière fois c'est quand j'avais 15 ans.
Je l'ai pas super bien vécu.
Tu viens la semaine prochaine chez Antoine pour profiter de la piscine,
tu pourras me passer de la crème solaire sur le corps.
Non je peux pas parce que je dois... je dois aller en Roumanie avec mes parents.
Ah, c'est bien de faire de l'humanitaire.
Je dormais chez un de mes cousins Roumain à Bucarest
et je sais que ça a pas mal changé depuis dix ans,
mais il y a un truc qui m'avait fasciné, c'était leur débrouille.
Les jeunes de l'immeuble avaient branché des câbles par la fenêtre
entre tous les ordinateurs de chaque étage qu'ils avaient reliés au cybercafé d'en bas.
Comme ça ils ne payaient qu'une seule connexion internet.
Il a pas Free, il s'en bat les couilles.
* parle en roumain*
J'avais oublié, j'avais oublié.
Et il y a un truc que j'ai pas très bien vécu, on peut dire ça comme ça.
Vous savez, en soirée il y a souvent un mec qui dit ça:
Oh Karim, c'est ta chanson, c'est ta chanson putain, allez viens danser, allez Karim!
Le raï, c'est pas mal, c'est pas mal le raï, c'est souvent des chansons d'amour.
Moi, j'avais ça:
Ohhhhh!
Ohhh! Cyprien!
Ça!
C'est ta chanson, allez!
Nu ma iei, nu ma iei!
Hein, dans ton pays, allez danse putain, c'est ta chanson Cyprien, nu ma iei.
De toutes les musiques... du monde,
il fallait,... il fallait que je sois assimilé à celle-ci, super!
Et quand je regardais le clip, je priais, mais je priais pour qu'ils passent tous à travers les pales de l'hélice.
Finalement avec le temps je me suis rendu compte que, on a les origines qu'on a,
il ne faut pas en avoir honte et considérer ça plutôt comme une richesse.
Abonnez-vous.
Ah! Il mendie des abonnés, le Roumain.